[music]
Hello everyone. Um, good afternoon. Uh,
well, this is me. Um, we are Limx
Dynamics. Um, you can see our logo on
all your badges. So, uh, so you can
remember us. And, um, one other thing
that's quite physical about our
representation here today, apart from me
being here, is um, one of our robots
actually being able to make it. Uh if
you just uh turn your heads over here,
this is um our flagship humanoid called
Ollie and uh courtesy of our very good
partners here in France um RW Robotics.
So
um just here to briefly tell you some
some information about our company, how
we approach robotics in general and how
I think uh uh China is evolving in the
robotics space.
So um we actually started the company in
2022 and when we first started the
company we asked we asked ourselves two
very important things. So what do what
does the ecosystem of robotics require
in the future and we basically came to
two conclusions that we we think are
quite important and uh these are these
are these are the things that really
started our company. One is we need two
robot product lines. One is a general
general purpose uh allpurpose you could
say humanoid. We as we've made here a
full-size full degree of freedom
humanoid. And the other thing we think
we we really need is a fully modular
robot that is uh opens up the
possibility of being optimized for every
specific scenario that our customers
want to participate in. So, um, for, uh,
people who are new to our brand, we
have, um, our general purpose humanoid
product lines. We call the OIE and the
Luna. Sad the Luna couldn't be here
today, but, um, there's the armored up
version of the Ollie. And we have our
Tron product lines, which is, um, the
world's first modular reconfigurable
robot. So with one hardware you can
actually get actually infinite forms out
of it because you can actually combine
different robots to form uh different
configurations uh that I'm going to show
you in a in a in a in a little bit. So
we have um a pretty comprehensive
hardware product line for every type of
customers who want to experiment who who
want to do a kind of scenario uh
experiment experimentation with robots
today.
Uh quite self-explanatory. Um our ollie
is um one of um the world's currently
most iconic uh full-size humanoid
products um that is uh available for
purchase actually available for shipping
worldwide. Um unfortunately it won't
come like this. Uh it will come without
the armor. Um but it's got 31 degrees of
freedom. Um 170 cm tall. So full size,
full degree of freedom capable of whole
body tracking and then full body local
manipulation. So this is a uh we call
our killer a killer platform for general
purpose humanoid robots.
Um some brief demonstrations here.
Actually very excited uh uh for um today
because we're actually premiering
something
and this is our robot in action. You
won't see this on this one
unfortunately, but um uh this is the
robot actually uh running a full body
local manipulation VA framework um kind
of uh adjusting to environment um
interacting with physical objects in
real time um and using whole body local
motion. So this is something very
important for us humanoid builders is to
be able to leverage full body motion
control in the motion in the uh
manipulation tasks that we actually
perform. So this is a very um tricky
task of uh trying to catch a tennis ball
that's in motion. So um it's it's very
different to the traditional pick and
place um tasks. We call this 3D pick and
place actually. So uh being able to
leverage whole body degrees of freedom
and being able to interact with objects
that are changing in location. So um
these are the these are the things that
we think are are are very important
foundational skills um for getting more
humanoids into more uh more useful
scenarios in the future. I'm going to
pause this. We have um
some more interesting stuff. So oh went
too far.
So our robots are interestingly uh not
really geared towards industrial use
cases. Um we like to more focus more a
little bit on uh service use cases
because um we build we build our
humanoids as lightweight multi-purpose
platforms uh that can actually serve
humans. So we don't want them to be
working in the manufacturing um uh kind
of in the in the manufacturing
production lines in replacement of a
human. Rather we want uh our our robots
to coexist very well with a human being.
So um the skills we train our robots to
do today are more uh relevant with uh
kind of uh service and commercial use
scenarios. Um and and dancing being a
very important for first step in in in
commercial delivering commercial value
to customers because uh dancing
obviously uh catches a lot of attention
and um this is how we're able to deliver
our first wave of ROI to our customers
by simply giving them more traffic in
the in the offline space. So currently
we work with a lot of um offline retail
chains. We work with a lot of automakers
uh to have robots actually being uh
being kind of salespeople in their in
their offline stores and and shops uh in
order to attract more attention to their
products. So I think this is one of the
first ways that humanoids uh is already
being used for um very real uh
returnbased scenarios in in the
commercial space. Um and uh we we can do
a we can do a dance on on on the Ali as
well a bit later.
Um, our Tron uh product is is what we
actually started the company on. Um,
it's it's one of our uh most it's the
it's the product that we're the most
proud of. Um, so on the left there you
can see the three configurations of Tron
which is a bipedal product and it at its
core. Uh, but we we're a we were able to
kind of multi-purpose uh achieve a
multi-purpose design with the limbs so
that you can actually change the legs
into into arms as well. So this is what
we call kind of an all-purpose a really
powerful u PC platform for all types of
uh scenarios that our customers our
partners may may want to enter. For
example uh the the bipedal wheelbased
platform you can use for uh inspection.
You can use for logistics. It can carry
up to 50 kilograms of weight. So a very
kind of heavy lifting um bipedal
platform. And you know with some simple
screwing uh you can change them into
arms very quickly. So they can do uh
dextrous manipulation work. Um and and
and this is at the price of only one
robot. So I think that's quite
important. Now for innovators who want
to do more with them, we can actually
support uh combinations of of different
forms. So we often ask ourselves, okay,
what if we uh in a scenario we want four
four legs and two arms, right? We we
should be able to make that sort of
robot ourselves as as customers. So uh
with the Tron 2 platform, we actually
achieved this. Um if you can see here,
we we actually did this ourselves. We
made kind of a centaur for form as well.
We uh using kind of the two lower body
and one upper body configuration and we
can actually make a quadripad. We can
make six legs, eight legs and so on.
Right? Depending on the scenario you
need, we can actually uh configure uh
reconfigure your hardware accordingly.
So um this is I think a very important
step forward for uh robotic hardware
innovation going into the future and uh
Limx is very proud to be the first
company in the world to actually do
something like this.
Um,
so this is actually what we call the
most powerful legs and most powerful
arms um in in condensed into one
product. So, so this is something we're
quite proud of.
And our newest product is um a fully
interactive, fully autonomous humanoid
we call Luna. It's it's got a very
feminine design. Um it's uh we ditched
the whole remote control thing entirely
and um we're basing every interaction uh
with the Luna on voice and visual
interactions. So um currently um so so
Luna is actually a very good product if
you want to uh for example have a
guidance robot, if you want to have a
sales robot uh that is fully
autonomously running today. So, you
know, it's very hard to actually get one
of these products in real life. And Luna
is is actually um one of the first
full-size humanoid um fully autonomous
um hardware platforms in the world that
you can actually purchase um that
actually achieves um what we actually
want humanoids to achieve.
Um as far as kind of uh systems go, we
we take this agentic approach. Um and I
think this is quite important. uh we
don't see the model or you know a
cluster of data as the brain of um of
the robot. We actually put a very big
emphasis on kind of the BLM uh section
in in the decision-m in that we think we
have you know very intelligent very
smart multimodal language based models
nowadays that we're not using properly.
um we're putting too much uh emphasis
into action um level generalization, you
know, scenario generaliz generalization
that we are kind of uh we're kind of you
know going away from how intelligent
these large language models today are.
So um we've kind of developed uh a three
system layer at the foundational level
is is what we call system zero which is
uh the whole body motion control which
is what you know enables the robot to
dance to jump to do back flips and all
that all that good stuff. in system one
are the specific skills
picking up objects, interacting, opening
doors, right? Going uh climbing stairs
and what really facilitates and what
orchestrates all that skill and um
decides when system zero comes into play
is um our cost system which is ouric
layer which really gives the robot that
high level of autonomy um that you know
all robot makers actually uh have
promised. So um you know versatile
interaction skills all the things you
expect from a good uh virtual agent
we've built into the robot physically uh
and that it can actually orchestrate it
can actually uh facilitate the different
skills and tools on board a robot and
make physical change in the physical
world. Um and and and and um if any of
you happen to be in uh Shenzhen in China
please let us know we have um an office
uh an office robot in our office
actually doing doing work for us
already. So, for example, if I want to
find somebody across the office, I'll
tell the robot, "Go see if such and such
person person is there and he will
understand that prompt. He will kind of
selfn himself over um tap him on the
shoulder lightly and say, you know,
Jesse's looking for you." And that's the
type of like fully agent, fully
autonomous robots that we're looking to
build. And you can imagine with more
skills, uh with better kind of uh with
more skills, more tools to orchestrate,
the robot will become increasingly
intelligent and increasingly useful in
the real world. So um that's uh our main
approach and going back to the beginning
one of the other questions that we asked
um ourselves when we founded the company
is what does the ecosystem really need
and we think um what the ecosystem lacks
is a good uh series of tool chains. So
I'm sure a lot of you in the audience
has have asked yourselves okay I want to
do something with robotics today where
should I start right you can buy
hardware you can buy oi but you actually
don't have the means to train it you
don't have the means to uh do you know
even higher level uh data manipulation
skills training um and this is why we
built a full suite of uh tool chains for
developers so you cannot you can both
you can actually um start from you know
nothing um have one of our plat uh
hardware platforms and have bas
basically have the entire training
infrastructure built out for you. Um our
newest platform um I'd like to emphasize
here today is our Flux VLA engine. Um
we're we're all familiar with VA um
hopefully now. Um but we think what's
important really is not the model itself
is the tool chain that really processes
the data a variety of different data and
actually outputs the model for the
customers. So for example, if I'm a
factory out in Switzerland and I I want
to buy a robot to do work on my
production line today, how do I gather
data, right? How do I train data
according to uh the robot configuration?
And um Flux VLA, I won't really go into
that much detail today, but it's a
project you can check out. It's an open-
source uh tool chain. It's an open
source platform that anyone can use and
you can start collecting data and
feeding it through Flux VLA and it will
output the model you need. you output
the policy you need uh to actually get
good results uh in in in a real
scenario. So um building tool chain tool
chains I think is is going to be a major
focus going forward for the company as
well.
Um and um you know it's a it's a great
platform here. I think we get you know
people coming from all over the world
and as a representative from China we'd
like kind of just like to update you
guys on where the industry is in general
in China. um because there is sometimes
an information gap. There is some sort
of information barrier. Uh you
definitely get more news regarding the
European and US uh companies here in
here here in France. Uh but it's a very
very vibrant it's a very active scene in
China as well. Um 2026
um real robot data I think it's going to
it's going to go 100x
uh compared to 2025. And this is being
very conservative. uh first-person video
a thousand times because we started from
basically nothing in 2025.
uh rapid transition out of VA based
frameworks to world action models. Could
be wrong, could be you know uh which
specific direction of world action
models the whole world is deciding right
but um I think I think the entire
industry in China uh it's rapidly moving
in that direction as well together with
the world uh and uh deploying robot uh
reinforcement learning in the real world
I think is going to be a theme in China
uh uh in 2026 as well. So
those are on data and models. hardware.
I think um supply chain advantage
remains in that um if you need cheap,
reliable uh good hardware such as the
Ali um it's very hard to surpass Chinese
supply chain and I think we'll we'll m
we'll um continue to make good hardware
going into the future and and be kind of
the leading innovators as as far as
hardware goes
and um we're we're innovating in more
practical directions in that um if you
look very closely at the industry in
China there are beginning uh uh we're
beginning to have more kind of targeted
uh uh kind of uh embodiment of robots
for example underwater for example uh
reconfigurable quadriped reconfigurable
bipedal robots um that are geared
towards kind of the last section I want
to highlight here is landing because uh
in China there is a larger pressure
than anywhere else in the world to land
robots on mass scale in scenarios today
and I think That's uh is what uh is
going to be truly important in pushing
kind of the next wave of robotics
improvement not just innovation but
robotics improvement is kind of
undergoing uh the scrutiny undergoing
kind of the challenges in a real
scenario and integrating with um on on a
mass scale not just on a PC scale on a
mass scale with kind of real customer
scenarios. So um uh I believe this is
going to happen faster in China than the
rest of the world. Um also uh you're
going to see a lot of standardized
scenario focused uh data sets and
solutions coming out of China together
with the hardware uh by the end of the
year. So um all robotics all robotics
companies in China are looking to uh
kind of step out from China go to you
know go global uh not just with hardware
but with kind of a more integrated
solution that has hardware in the middle
and kind of uh scenario level knowhow
and data and uh solutions surrounding
it. uh you know as as a whole package.
So uh this is something that's happening
in China today.
Um my last two minutes I'm I'm going to
talk about a topic called the new China
global partnership. I think this is very
important for the global ecosystem. Um
I think increasingly with kind of
innovations in AI and with more funding
going into this this space uh good
hardware is going to be more and more
crucial. So um one of our key tasks at
Limx is uh make that thing as reliable
or as good or as cheap as we possibly
can. Um so that we can actually enable
uh one uh kind of what we call oneplus 1
is larger than two uh partnerships. Um a
lot of kind of mature uh solutions and a
lot of scenarios have already formed in
China. Example, for inspection and
logistics, you use quadrips, we use
bipedal robots. Um, uh, bipedal
humanoids more towards kind of service
scenarios, commercial scenarios. And the
wheelbased dual arm, uh, configuration
is is more, um, popular within
production, uh, production manufacturing
scenarios in China.
Um, and tool chain plus data, I think,
is very important because a lot of the
tool chains we build because we actually
make the hardware ourselves. So the tool
chains are actually very closely
integrated with the hardware we saw. Um
and I think it's um it's very important
for us uh as hardware makers to make the
accurate the correct uh tool chains to
enable more and more people around the
world to get into this field uh what we
call kind of ecosystem partners uh who
want to develop more applications uh
higher level applications um and and
really surprise us as um as the the
device manufacturers or as kind of the
makers of the humanoids. um so we get a
more vibrant a more kind of
collaborative uh kind of open uh
environment or open ecosystem in the
future. So I think tool chain will be
very uh crucial in that in building that
ecosystem um and uh we will be kind of
uh pushing our tool chain out uh to our
customers and partners around the world
uh in the coming months um together with
our hardware. So
um yep and uh right on time 20 minutes.
Thank you guys for your attention and um
have a good rest of the conference.
Thank you
and thank you. Yeah, there you go.
And big shout out to my friend RW
Robotics. Thank you, man. Thank you,
man.